esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café una emisión producida por la
sección en español del difusor público
radio canadá internacional difundimos
los viernes a las dos y cuarto por las
redes sociales en internet en esta
emisión les presentamos los temas
destacados de la semana y también
compartimos sus mensajes enviados por
correo electrónico este programa se
encuentra disponible en nuestro sitio en
internet r design & punto o sea si
quieren escribirnos para pueden hacerlo
a la dirección electrónica hablar
heresi net punto o sea hoy les acompañan
en los micrófonos
pablo gómez barrios chapman leonardo
gimeno y giles habla ruso valencia en la
versión radio de este programa
disponible en nuestro sitio en internet
les presentaremos música del grupo
canadiense arcade fire también estará la
voz de la quebequense de redmonk aun
interpretando un tema de david bowie del
canadiense william turner escucharemos
la canción medio time
de david bowie justamente una sugestión
de nuestro amigo leonardo escucharemos
el tema la sal es clavado poco antes de
su muerte es tener algún black star que
aparece el 8 de enero de 2016 y bobby
fallece dos días más tarde el 10 de
enero hoy se cumplen tres años de la
desaparición física del vil bowl igual
su música sigue
su legado siempre está presente con
nosotros pero bueno es un momento
especial para recordar esa música será
que esta canción nada el anillo del
capitán better se inspiran en bowie
es probable claro que sí
y el tema de la relación con arquette
fire es porque debí bougherra fanático
de este grupo canadiense este reciente
entre comillas grupo canadiense montreal
encia particularmente y una de sus
presentaciones cuando ya estaban en la
palestra de la música en serio digamos
no habían dejado ser un grupo under
bowie vino a montreal y subió con ellos
porque en realidad vino a verlo a ver el
grupo porque le gustaba y él pidió subir
a tocar una canción con eso imagínate la
de tocar con nosotros los bienvenido sea
david bowie así que una relación muy
especial con la música canadiense
también bowie claro y justamente quién
va a decirle que no
yo no mejor quédate ahí míranos bien
pablo entonces empecemos con las
noticias que les hayan llamado atención
esta semana y algo que puedas destacar
el que espera que un momentito
estamos despertando al 2019 y es
justamente algo que yo también olvidaba
decir a otros amigos estoy buscando las
cámaras aquí y aquí ya que todas las dos
pues bienvenidos al 2019 saludos a todos
los con ustedes y bien en noticia
noticia como tal me sorprendió un poco
una noticia que salió esta semana de
un inmigrante indigente de origen
con goles creo que durante el invierno
se debió me imagino dormir afuera y se
le congelaron las piernas y parte y
algunos dedos entonces lo llevaron al
hospital y los médicos en el hospital en
el centro en el sur que es el centro
hospitalario de la universidad de
montreal bueno decidieron que había que
cortar la vía que amputarle las piernas
y algunos dedos y el paciente el tipo se
opuso radicalmente a que amputaron las
piernas a que le hicieran las
amputaciones y el caso entonces los
médicos del hospital fueron ante un
tribunal para pedirles que
si podían hacerle la amputación por la
fuerza clara al tipo porque este es ya
bueno sí pero está que ese es el
problema que el juez dijo que no
entonces el juez no les permitió que
hicieran la amputación forzada forzosa
porque era contra su voluntad y que él
aunque aunque estuviera prácticamente
condenado a muerte si no se le cortan la
organogénesis ept iu-cm ya entonces hay
una infección general pero después dijo
que no se le podía cortar puede hacer la
amputación si él no estaba de acuerdo
con que se le hiciera entonces pues eso
fue el 15 de diciembre el que que lo
llevaron al hospital a buscar sus
mejores hace casi un mes y bueno y ayer
esta semana el 5
este miércoles que pasó el juez dijo que
no que no se podía no pasa al parecer
está todavía vivo pero él el juez dijo
que no se le podía hacer la amputación
contra su voluntad
o sea que bueno la persona acepta el
final
exacto ciento se quiere morir completo
decide que no iba no presente no sé cómo
va a terminar la historia porque bueno
eso fue esta semana que salió como no
pero puede perder la pierna es la vida
lo que está en juego porque las piernas
de todas formas los médicos las quieren
amputar porque se pueden gangrena o
están en camino de entonces finalmente
es la vida porque si le da una infección
generalizada debe tener otras creencias
entonces para negarse
tú tienes algo que me sorprendió y es
porque conozco mucha gente que lo hace
en una gran investigación que se hizo
que sobre la aspirina y que determinó
que la aspirina como medida de
prevención en la gente mayor no sirve
para nada y al contrario puede ser más
bien un problema puede crear otros
problemas de salud en las personas tiene
que ver con la cuestión coronaria
cuando uno está se siente pero en
realidad no sé cómo son los pasos
previos pero cuando uno siente que tiene
un ataque al corazón
la recomendación es masticar una
aspirina eso si funciona presta porque
hablando de prevención
a partir de eso hace un montón de años
que se dice que a la gente que es
propensa a cuestiones cardíacas tomar
una aspirina que viene una aspirina
especiales y son bajas desocupados de
bajas dosis tomar una por día eso
ayudaba a prevenir
cuestiones coronarias pero dice que no
justamente que no digo esto me llama la
atención porque yo conozco gente que
toma una baja de 80 miligramos muy baja
no todos los días y que creen que es una
medida para prevenir las crisis
cardíacas y otro tipo de enfermedades
esta investigación dice que es
absolutamente negativo
miles de personas participaron en esta
investigación de australia y eeuu con
poblaciones mayores de 70 años propensas
al envejecimiento propensas a tener
crisis cardíacas y que vienen tomando
desde hace años pues estas aspirinas
entonces para como medida de prevención
recomiendan no tomar íntimamente una
persona se convierte en persona mayor
bueno yo creo que en este momento si
lees y la investigación decía que había
que tener como mínimo 70 años se
considera una persona de 70 años mayor
supongo ya yo más o menos es el café
entonces porque hay estudios que dicen
que el café es bueno en los que el café
es malo al final
a la cuestión yo me imagino que con el
café es cuestión de no exagerar tampoco
o sea el café tiene buenas cosas si lo
tomas moderadamente como toda la vida no
es moderado
no sé comer carne mañana tarde y noche
no es bueno el 8 -quinteto al día la
lechuga está al día eso todavía no lo
encuentran lo malo
la lechuga hay un problema el problema
es que tenga el colín o no la historia
es bueno el big size me se acuerdan de
ese documental se documental
sigo ver size me' o big sight ninguna
cosa así el tipo como mcdonald's me
desayuno almuerzo variando escena
durante un mes o dos meses y el cambio
en su cuerpo radical es una locura pero
es lo que decía salió me acuerdo un
documentalista italiano diciendo en
aquella época como pasta
obviamente va a tener problemas solo
carne
obviamente el tema es una dieta
equilibrada todo el supuesto equilibrio
siempre toda su medida y armoniosamente
esa siempre escucha la palabra chiquita
me acuerdo de mafalda y no se siente una
tortuga mafalda manolito pero es de
tortuguitas que dice chiquita para
tortuguitas
esto es entonces esa investigación que
me parece que era importante por eso
pues conozco gente muy cercana que éste
toma todo que se se suministra las
aspirinas todos los días entonces
cuidado con eso porque puede traer otros
problemas si bueno el tema también me
llama la atención bueno ustedes saben
que a partir del 18 de diciembre hay una
ley nueva que la policía puede pararlo a
uno manejando sin ningún problema para
hacerle un test de intoxicación y
alcoholemia y
pero con otro tipo de drogas resulta que
la ley es bastante compleja y tiene un
par de elementos que no yo no conocía
particularmente y lo escuché hacer y me
pareció realmente ridículo la policía yo
me estoy enfrente de tu casa te veo
llegar y digo a este muchacho parece que
estuvo tomando llamó a la policía y la
policía puede entrar a tu casa acepte el
test hasta dos horas después de haber
llegado
y si te encuentras con alcohol en una
multa no tiene por qué casi con un poco
de vino
eso es lo que decía la persona y
justamente una eléctrica
[Risas]
exacto no profesional en es una locura
que tengan la potestad de entrar a tu
casa y acepte un análisis cuando está
claro
simplemente esto que estás diciendo no
creo en su aplicación
ellos pueden por ejemplo sospechar de
que estuviste en una fiesta y de salir y
después seguir en el auto ahora ir a tu
vida privada
eso es parte de la
y tú puedes llegar a tu casa puedes no
haber tomado un solo trago en el
trayecto a tu casa y apenas llegas te
sirve es un whisky doble y te lo manda
de un solo trago
yo lo que quería es más hace un par de
días mataron a un muchacho que fue a
devolver seis cajas de cerveza
fue un supermercado que también es
consignada entonces devuelven 5 centavos
entonces esta persona fue devolvió seis
cajas de botellas y cuando salió le
hiciera el test porque sospechados y si
tienes probablemente están buscando una
manera de hacer horas extras al paciente
y hay otra ley también por ahí que hay
problemas para la gente con asma que
para quien la está el test de
alcoholemia puede ser negativo puede
tener consecuencias en la salud de estas
personas asmáticas se aro porque la
espiración durante 15 segundos seguidas
cuando uno tiene una crisis de asma es
imposible entonces además puede provocar
tal vez un examen o bueno en cuanto a lo
que a mí me llamó la atención de semana
justamente hablando lechuguita si carnes
y estas cosas
científicos científicos e investigadores
en yukón encontraron que finalmente las
liebres no son no son vegetarianas
también se comen a otras liebres
inclusive se comen a los linces
para atacar un link está enfermo y viejo
si se graba en el cambio concreto es que
estos conejos estas libres comen son
carnívoras son caníbales que comen en
ese comentario es también absolutamente
han detectado o sea usando cámaras de
sensoras infrarrojas y también
detectores de movimiento
justamente detectados y ahora que no
encuentran comida rucks y justamente
dice que ésta está aquí está en alguna
foto que seguramente no se puede ver
pero quizás lo encuentran más tarde pero
es una foto en la que se ve a una a una
liebre comiéndose a otra liebre y han
hecho nos decían que no es solamente un
caso único se debe llamar aníbal
y lo cierto es que no habría esta
definición tan clara nítida de
herbívoros y carnívoros sino que en
determinados momentos del año
son pues comentamos que hay
de alimentos en aquel momento
desesperación se comen entre ellos o es
un hábito
seguramente que es un hábito permanente
porque es en función también de cuando
por ejemplo cayó un metro de nieve en
ciertas regiones en la costa del
atlántico tú eres una liebre como te vas
a poner a cavar un metro para encontrar
cómo se encuentra es una una liebre una
amiga es para nada
[Risas]
entonces las liebres son caníbales para
los veganos
y aquí tengo salud mental y hay gente
que empieza interactuar
césar rodríguez charlize no creo que sea
bueno da taquicardia si toma varias
tazas al día
este café que tomamos no es café no
igual yo me levanto con un llego a mi
casa otros pre citó avante a dormir
otros tres hitos y en el café ni en el
trabajo tomábamos café y resulta que el
otro día machines también todos los
negros tomamos escuché que el que la
cantidad de cafeína que tiene un expreso
es mucho menor que la cantidad de
cafeína que tiene un café filtró exacto
así porque le decíamos que no
en contacto con el agua el filtro el
agua cae en el filtro y después va
dejando justamente filtrar el líquido en
el expreso es agua hirviendo a presión
que para secar no hay tiempo de contacto
interesantes bueno descubrimos con la
iglesia nos dice si el café es de
colombia si es bueno y mejor tomar vino
rojo tomar vino rojo
europa cuando la policía está cerca pero
si es bueno si tomar tinto está ahí
viene la confusión entre colombianos y
argentino a mí me pasó a mí mientras yo
en españa con dos colombianos estábamos
haciendo un curso en madrid y me dijeron
esta tarde esta noche nos juntamos a
tomar un tintico yo para tomar café
porque al equipo de venezuela le dicen
tinto la vinotinto por el color de la
camiseta
rené betancourt dice saludos al equipo
de profesionales del seguir viendo la
transmisión en oxaca méxico
está allí está el restaurant las letras
elfa beto letras un restaurant
vegetariano alguien oaxaca quiero en
sopa de letras sopa de letras llamar el
restorán exactamente sopa de letras y
hay comida vegetariana lo cual es
extraño pero excelente porque porque
extraño porque la dieta mexicana es
sobre todo carnívora
tenemos a su rival de valles que dice
saludos desde méjico excelente programa
los iguales
efe de que parte dice desde méxico así
que en todo caso si nos está escuchando
que nos diga de dónde y cuándo nos
escuchan
tener alguien es brasil porque no
sabemos qué está pasando por allá de
remedios militares nelsy remedy vidal
nos escucha también por internet vienen
todos estamos con méxico colombia méjico
colombia
en méxico en este bailarín de la
argentina la violencia bien muy bien
entonces esas noticias vamos ahora
recuerdo que en temas de música
escucharemos el tema reflector del grupo
aquel fire con la donde se puede
escuchar la voz de david bowie y de
huevo y la canción ashes to ashes más
tarde interpretada por la quebequense 3
mon camps el canadiense william shatner
con la canción con mucho humor mayor
town y finalmente de eso de ti y no se
llama mejor com es una canción
space oddity sí sí el que él sea
apasionado una versión especial entonces
le cambió el nombre si están débiles de
escuchar ni tienen a una versión del
himno canadiense que nadie
hace una versión del himno canadiense
que en otras épocas y nuestras regiones
de américa tiene lo fusilaban
instantáneamente porque es muy crítico
como pero con eso
muy suyo es excelente esa versión
entonces eso creemos que tenemos hoy
para ustedes en un programa en línea en
este programa línea y vamos a pasar
ahora los mensajes de nuestros amigos
yo tengo dos sobre dos comentarios sobre
justamente el programa canadá en las
américas café del castor cibernético
leslie mann dice me encanta tu programa
gracias y después nelsy remedy me dar
dice gracias radio canadá internacional
por canadá en las américas café el
castor cibernético abrazos yo aquí tengo
una carta larga que escribe
rodrigo vega gamarra y cuervo sobre
alegando una crisis fronteriza trump
insistirá en construir su muro y de leer
el principio es bueno después se dejó
para que 12 que te haga intención vayan
a leer el texto completo está contando
los minutos para ver en qué momento
entraba la palabra trampas programa la
construcción dice de murallas en las
fronteras de los países y en las
ciudades es una constante en la historia
de los pueblos para garantizar su
seguridad
el amor es de china para detener las
invasiones de los mongoles los muros de
adriano y antonio en escocia para
detener y controlar a los celtas
más recientemente la línea más jim no
está construida por francia después de
la primera guerra mundial en su frontera
con italia y alemania eso aparte de la
cantidad de ciudades amuralladas que han
existido a lo largo de la historia
hace un par de años había hecho un
especial que llamaba a los muros
justamente que hablaba de los muros
físicos más importantes que existen hoy
en la tierra y no había una parte que
era por supuesto el muro en eeuu la
parte que ya está construida está
construida y bueno y ahí voy a hablarles
nuevamente de muros hoy porque hay una
exposición interactiva que comienza
mañana en la cinemateca quebequense de
un artista quebequense que se llama
martín group y él grabó es es una es una
instalación no y construyó muros en la
cinemateca quebequense que se asemejan
muchos son exactos a los muros que hay
entre israel y palestina y al muro que
hay en irlanda en el irlanda del norte
que separa a ambos bandos estaban
vacilantes y
y el de méxico eeuu el de trump entonces
este artista estuvo en esos lugares
filmó los muros y tomó fotos y todo esto
entonces una es una instalación
interactiva en la que puedes informarte
sobre la situación de los muros en el
mundo y que comienza mañana aquí en
montreal en la cinemateca la ironía es
que justamente también aparte de
montreal en la parte internacional de
montreal en el centro internacional hay
un fragmento y un pedazo del muro de
berlín y está expuesto en exposición ahí
es una celebración justamente de la
caída del muro y estamos en contra esto
es justamente en que más bien se hace un
elogio de los muros
elogió como para por ejemplo dentro y lo
vamos a hablar después en la crónica que
yo hago para este fin de semana es de la
c s que es la gran feria mundial de
cuestiones de tecnología y hay gente que
está vendiendo la idea de un muro
virtual con alta tecnología para evitar
que la gente se acerque y tal pero no
físicos sino en eeuu y mentes
dt marcan 5
ciertamente se detectan cuando quieres
intentar pasar así que toda una nueva
tecnología ahora trump dijo
recientemente que la admiraba el muro de
israel que construyó israel que son 500
y pico de kilómetros no y que la idea de
israel es llegar a construir 700 y pico
de kilómetros dime a quién eras miras y
te diré quién eres
no claro efectivamente si entonces me
eso de nuevas tecnologías tal vez será
la opción en caso de que no consiga los
miles de millones de dólares que está
exigiendo leal al gobierno a su propio
gobierno y bocatas plantean es la
propuesta demócrata de usar otras
tecnologías menos no sean el muro examen
de cemento y de concreto y todo eso sí
pero igualmente lo raro es que estén
planteando una opción de otro tipo de
muro los demócratas también exactamente
y eso prueba que entre demócratas y
republicanos en materia de polis
por lo menos y mucha política interna
hay una coincidencia total
en los partidos políticos son así me
recuerdo en mi época joven había un
dicho en colombia si césar chávez
chari rodríguez está ya está ahí se
recordará que decía bueno durante mucho
tiempo fueron los partidos por la
primera vez esta vez este en las últimas
elecciones fue un partido distinto a los
tradicionales liberal y conservador que
gobernaron el país desde la república
desde que comenzó la república y se
decía en colombia que la diferencia
entre los liberales y los conservadores
era que los conservadores iban a la misa
de 5 y los liberales a la misa de 6 y el
resto pues lo mismo no se mezclaban y no
hay absolutamente ninguna diferencia y
es más o menos lo que ocurre con los
demócratas y los republicanos en ese
aspecto si los republicanos van a
mcdonald's y los demócratas van a
starbucks
bien entonces vamos ahora a entrar a los
temas de la semana y justamente
empecemos contigo leonardo que
justamente ya hacía referencia a este
célebre este evento que se lleva a cabo
todos los años y que empieza el 67 y
hace más de 50 años
en nueva york casi 52 años precisamente
en realidad se hizo el primer nueva york
y después empezó a hacer
en donde se hace ahora y mi partida
traigas las vegas y tiene la
particularidad de que estamos hablando
que es como el arte helenístico de
tecnología donde las grandes casas
tecnológicas del mundo hay más de 1.600
expositores van y presentan sus nuevos
descubrimientos las cosas que se vienen
y bueno en prometer actualmente las
novedades y en este caso lo más
llamativo fue bueno en la pronta
implementación de las redes 5g
para poder habilitar todo el resto de
las invenciones que vienen porque lo que
pasa es que si hoy conectamos todos esos
aparatos que están en la feria a la
misma red con la que usamos nuestros
teléfonos hoy en día la red colapsaría
entonces primero que nada la red 5g para
poder expandir la capacidad y la
velocidad de internet para poder
soportar todos estos otros arrollada sí
sí sí están están haciendo tests en
europa y en eeuu algunas partes están
haciendo test muy particulares las
grandes empresas de microchips ya están
lanzando los chips para poner los
teléfonos que juntos las grandes chinas
y samsung ya dijeron que prontamente
para sacar un modelo con un chip 5g y
ese es justamente el trasfondo del duelo
entre eeuu y chinchiná exacto exacto uno
de ellos en realidad y la otra historia
es que hay desarrollos que son
fantásticos y desarrollos que uno no
tiene de las que están
pero wang algo deben ser vino no pero es
por ejemplo un robot que lo sigue a uno
en la calle que le dice cuándo comer que
comer para cuidar la salud
que tiene el algoritmo que va
aprendiendo y le va enseñando a comer en
vivo y en directo después un taxi
hyundai presentó una especie de taxi en
realidad un auto híbrido y con patas que
puedes subir a las escaleras de
edificios para bajar a las personas
minusválidas por ejemplo caramba o
entrar en terrenos de poca gente de poca
posibilidad de acceso con un auto común
después por ejemplo hay una pequeña me
acuerdo de la empresa que lo hizo pero
es una pequeña
máquina para hacer cerveza casera
algoritmo que va aprendiendo mientras
uno va haciendo para que para mejorar el
producto final después en el stand
canadiense se presentó una especie de
mueble donde uno puede plantar tomates
lechugas y no me acuerdo qué otro tipo
de verduras
hacer las que sea en casa y por supuesto
la tecnología tiene que ver con nitro
fuego en cantidad la cantidad de agua
que se le pone la temperatura excelente
para propiciar el crecimiento así que
hay cosas fantásticas un reloj nuevo de
estos relojes inteligentes que se
recarga con el calor humano o sea que no
debería uno sacárselo nunca más podría
uno estar conectado con los posibles con
el impacto exacto que no vaya moverse
ese reloj pero bueno de estas cientos de
cosas nuevas
yo voy a seleccione un 45 que me
llamaron atención no todas porque hay
cosas que son desopilantes de cosas que
tienen que ver con
el cuidado de la gente por ejemplo
muchísimas aplicaciones y dispositivos
para cuidar a la gente para para mejorar
por ejemplo hay un dispositivo para
enseñarle a los padres primerizos como
los los para entender el llanto del bebé
para que el padre primerizo pueda
decodificar la desgracia eso no lo tiene
que aprender sobre la marca con el bebé
evitar el aprendizaje de nuestro
aprendizaje la mano esta gente le ofrece
su poco iba a ver gente y todo lo que se
ve ahí hay algún elemento que es posible
que sea el más el que más difusión tenga
no no yo creo que en realidad hay un
montón de prototipos está bien y esa es
la muestra es la feria justamente para
mostrar para poder juntar dinero lo que
me llama la atención es que yo estaba
buscando su internet al día siguiente me
dio una publicidad del crowdfunding del
reloj este que se carga
y alguien tiene que juntar un millón y
medio de dólares y como yo estuve
mirando la noticia y tenía interés en
eso hice clic y lo busqué al día
siguiente me llegó no quiere colaborar
en leonora ahora es decir que alguien es
un chancho puede ser positivo puede ser
muy positivo y puede ser un algo
milagroso eso es bueno es una nueva
investigación pero además una
investigación que dio resultados y eso
es el tema es que se utilizaron
corazones de cerdos sobre animales en
este caso se está hablando bueno un
grupo de científicos que llevaron a cabo
un experimento de trasplante del corazón
del chancho del cerdo hacia estos monos
babuinos que tienen una cara un poco
extraña estos monos una cara larga los
colores azules
el tema es que el tema es que lograron
mantener con vida a estos monos babuinos
durante casi 200 días es algo inédito
agua o lo que por supuesto que lo que
uno sabe es que el trasplante salva
vidas humanas el tema es que hay muy
pocos donantes de en este caso del
corazón entonces desde hace muchísimo
tiempo los científicos científicos
vienen ensayando el proceso de
trasplante que se llama
como se llama cuando es con entre
animales de distintas entre personas de
entre entre entre distintas especies se
llama cse no sé no trasplante lo vienen
ensayando desde hace muchísimo tiempo y
encontraron que lo más compatible y ese
es el resultado es trabajar con el
chancho porque el chancho porque el
corazón del chancho se parece mucho al
corazón del ser humano no entonces han
hecho eso hay médicos que dicen que esto
es un milagro que hoy se puede decir que
en muy pocos años y eso es el milagro va
a ver el corazón de chancho va a ser
utilizado para el trasplante en seres
humanos algo impensable hace algunos
pocos hay algo simbólico con el award
son a la parrilla no había parte en el
resto puede la pérdida y la otra parte
es cuidar cuidar el corazón porque
justamente el chancho limpio nunca
engorda y engordar trae complicaciones
coronarias así que claro bueno y hubo
también complicaciones hubo muchas
medidas que se tomaron por ejemplo en
uno de los problemas más serios y que
lograron resolver estos científicos es
el caso el bueno este es uno pero el
corazón al estar cuando es un trasplante
de un ser humano se saca el corazón de
la persona y se lo pone en hielo
inmediatamente y se lo mantiene vivo y
se lo traslada eso lo lleva al paciente
receptor que también tiene sus riesgos
pero en los los monos que fueron
transplantados reaccionaban de distinta
manera y el corazón se moría casi
inmediatamente aunque lo pusieran en
hielo en fin entonces toda una serie de
experimentos llegaron hasta hasta lograr
construir un sistema de soporte que
dicen que es realmente revolucionario
que se compara con una pequeña unidad de
cuidados intensivos para el órgano y que
logran mantener funcionando los
corazones hasta que se lo trasplante en
este caso a los muros héctor clase el
logrado y vivieron 200 días esto es muy
importante lo que hicieron estos médicos
y se está hablando ya de un milagro
entonces no se sorprendan si tienen un
tiempo muy corto los corazones de
chanchos
permitir salvar muchas vidas humanas
de mi corazón mentalmente naturalmente y
mentalmente saber que el corazón es un
órgano muy importante tenemos
restricciones para la gente que por
ejemplo para aquellos que tienen el
chancho como un animal sucio todas las
grandes las grandes religiones
manes que no comen chancho imagínense
diciéndole te voy a salvar la vida pero
todo por un corrupción de chancho bueno
yo creo que en este caso van a aceptar
cualquier persona que esté con peligro
de morirse pues probablemente no
permiten la transfusión sanguínea y hay
quienes prefieren morir porque no caen
no la permiten porque además no creen
que eso signifique que van a salvar en
este caso si te dicen presse cierto la
cuestión de la religión es una cuestión
muy delicada muy particular pero es
cierto decir que se basa un corazón de
chancho en tu cuerpo hola la
pero lo cierto es que es como dicen un
médico del hospital de toronto decía que
esto hay que considerarlo como el gran
gran se dice la alegría
es una gran investigación el resultado
es realmente es algo excepcional con con
piñones hace unos años atrás también
riñones de chancho xxi que los riñones
humanos y los chachos son los que más se
compatibles son más compatibles es
probable no sé que tiene el chancho pero
esto que tenemos nosotros es una buena y
olvidó las chanchadas en política pero
es cierto entonces de qué va a ser
milagroso el tema porque hay mucha gente
que muere pues porque justamente en un
corazón que llegue a tiempo si son de
melón
todavía no es interesantísimo cortito
aquí con como es el tema de la ablación
de órganos aquí
uno tiene que decir que si en tu carta
de asma de ti o que puedes firmar la
donación de órganos en poquitos días en
argentina se aceptó la ley no me acuerdo
el nombre
creo que es una niña que murió por falta
de las posibilidades de un órgano para
ser trasplantado y hoy en día en
argentina el médico no tiene que tener
la autorización de la familia para hacer
la ablación había el proyecto en que el
proyecto de que no automáticamente la
persona que muera
voluntario al menos que tú digas o al
menos que te opongas que me parece que
sería más razonable efectivamente un
mensaje leonardo si aquí en el valle se
nos dice hidalgo y del brasileño pero
vivo acá saludos
nosotros que pedíamos brasileño
brasileña mira
bien y volvemos entonces a esta lista de
los policías y conducir el paro tú nos
hablas ahora de un accidente de tránsito
que tuvo un final sorprendente en las
cortes de la provincia de québec exacto
así lo insólito fue lo que sucedió lo
que la chica que fue víctima
propuso resulta que esta niña en ese
momento debía tener como 20 o 21 años
eso sucedió cerca de bali field entonces
ella iba haciendo suyo quin con una
amiga en una de las calles de bali de
valley field y al mismo tiempo había
otro muchacho ella se llama tina adams y
el muchacho se llama a jordan xavier
taylor york danzabierta y lord él por su
parte estaba en una fiesta en el club de
golf
the valley field y bueno festejaron
mucho y él decidió al final de la fiesta
de regresar a su casa con su automóvil
en el camino de regreso atropelló a las
dos chicas no las mató pero las
atropelló a las dos chicas y bueno eso
fue que se habló de esto porque el fallo
o no el fallo porque el juez pidió un
poco más de tiempo para reflexionar pero
pasaron en la corte este miércoles
pasado y esta chica en las consecuencias
de ese accidente fue que tuvieron que
reemplazarle la cadera y le tuvieron que
reconstruir la pelvis porque el impacto
fue muy fuerte entonces en total ha
tenido 19 operaciones y sufre de dolores
crónicos entonces los abogados
defensor y el abogado de la chica
entonces se había puesto de acuerdo ya
habían hablado y habían conversado con
el juez y habían propuesto unánimemente
los dos las dos partes de proponer una
pena de ocho meses de cárcel
permiso de conducir suspendido por 18
meses y un año de libertad condicional
ese era lo que los abogados habían
propuesto entonces se presentaron se
presentó la causa en la corte esta
semana como decía y en un momento dado
la chica se levantó cuando se
el acusado vino a verla y se disculpó y
le dijo de que lamentaba lo que había
ocurrido y todo esto entonces la chica
le explicó al juez cuando tomó la
palabra que ella desde ese accidente
estaba dando conferencias en las
escuelas para sensibilizar a los jóvenes
sobre el problema del alcohol al volante
y de conducir su carro
intoxicado con alcohol entonces lo que
sorprendió a todos es que ella le
propuso al juez antes de que diera sus
años y le propuso que lo que ella pedía
y lo que ella quería es que ese muchacho
el acusado la acompañará a ella en sus
conferencias le daba para sensibilizar a
los chicos en las escuelas y el muchacho
aceptó y el muchacho aceptó me pareció y
todo el mundo le parece increíble que la
chica hubiera propuesto eso y ella
ya venía madurando su idea antes de
pasar ante el tribunal y el día no le
contó ni siquiera a su familia porque no
quería que nadie le hiciera cambiar de
idea nadie así entonces cuando ella se
levantó era la primera vez que exponía
su idea y sorprendió incluso a su propio
padre que sé si me esperaba eso nada
entonces hizo el peligroso al juez
también porque el fallo se iba a dar ahí
pero teniendo en cuenta su pedido el
juez propuso que se pusiera hasta el 27
de enero para mi historial de estudiar
el caso y poder dar el fallo entonces la
idea es que él acompañe a la chica en su
ocurren esas conferencias de
sensibilización de sensibilización del
alcohol al volante estas historias están
disponibles en nuestro sitio en internet
eres init punto sea personalmente yo le
recomiendo escuchar una entrevista con
el profesor simon granovsky larsen quien
enseña en el departamento de ciencias
políticas en la universidad regina él ha
dedicado su atención a la situación en
guatemala
es económicas entre canadá y guatemala y
lo que él sostiene es básicamente es que
el neoliberalismo en guatemala no puede
funcionar sin violencia y además
interesante presentaba también como
ejemplo lo que acaba de suceder en
canadá esta semana donde un grupo de
indígenas que defendían su terreno los
web suben en color y británica ellos que
no se vieron sus territorios tuvieron
que hacer frente a una operación cuasi
militar de la policía federal y él decía
justamente hubo detención
como el señor se detenidos y este
profesor decía qué bueno que las luchas
en guatemala o en colombia o en canadá
son similares es decir que es un modelo
económico que se lo asume como algo
natural el neoliberalismo y que necesita
en el fondo estos mismos instrumentos
para su aplicación entonces está la
entrevista con este profesor simon
granovsky larsen un canadiense que
aprendió el español y que estuvo varios
por varios años en guatemala
siguiendo justamente la evolución del
movimiento campesino en ese país
bien amigos entonces una última mirada a
algún mensaje de nuestros amigos en
internet en este caso dice quince mil
personas en la lista de deportación de
canadá pero algunos países no los
quieren de regreso dicen esposos cubanos
no le aceptaron en refugio está con
orden de deportación cubano lo acepta
pues perdió su estatus estamos casados
lo apadrinó y tampoco lo aceptaron con
un comportamiento intachable él creó su
propia compañía pagando sus impuestos y
sin ningún tipo de sanción no tiene
ningún tipo de récord en la justicia
está limpio y canadá y cuba no los
aceptan
realmente hay cosas que están pasando en
este país es decir personas como él
siete años firmando cada cinco 15 días
petitorios y siguen pasando este tipo de
cosas bueno el mensaje también es largo
y allí nos cuenta de gente que está
viviendo en el mundo de los mismos tipos
de casos y que realmente no hay salida
para esta gente y bien amigos de esta
después de esa última carta aquí
llegamos al final de nuestro programa
estaremos con ustedes la próxima semana
creo que es para bloque
a la tiene esta silla de la próxima
semana entonces gracias pablo gracias
gracias
leonardo gracias amigos con la canción
de los espías feliz año nuevo nuevamente
lo mejor para ustedes en el 2019 feliz
año adiós adiós